[Musique]
mes chers fait je vous ai convoqué car
l'heure est grave
dans cinq jours notre belle au bois
dormant aura dormi 100 ans
si aucun prince ne vient la réveiller
elle disparaître blondinet mélusine vous
allez aller chercher ce grâce à paris
gilles les amours
garde y en a deux piles huiles grand
dieu ça va être tellement facile beau
évidemment courageux savez-vous monde à
cheval
oui oui un sportif intelligent le
sportif intelligente du corps et marque
avec des pressions des numéros ces
pratiques
[Musique]
alors un homme tu aimes les hommes ça
peut pas le faire je suis très bien quoi
vous a confié une mission et tout le
monde compte sur deux jours à peine
c'est qu'on cherche un breizh pour ya
pas de précis quelque chose des gros
débiles et l'accès au supermarché c'est
les jambes ça n'existe pas vraiment donc
mon frère guillaume
blandine et mêle aisément chanter gear
en arctique
j'ai envie de voyager d'avoir des
enfants du phare site vraiment alors on
en voit maintenant mais si personne mais
la belle on va tous crever
belleau wood monde attend non pas faute
aux bisous comment on va faire on
tombera jamais rien ne put price fermé
leur la tour eiffel